united states and other allies imposing
strict sanctions on russia's ultra-rich
oligarchs seven of russia's wealthiest
and most influential oligarchs were just
targeted in the uk they've been very
strong on this their assets have been
frozen and they are banned from their
country until now they have lived
lavishly in sprawling london estates
driving hundreds of thousands of cars
and talking about everything you want
from big yachts to big planes joining us
now a guy that doesn't have either but
could eventually if he wanted to because
he's that valuable as a speaker and as a
writer douglas murray welcome back great
pleasure boxers contributors are doing a
great job hosting that show at six
o'clock uh and you have a a big book
coming out but douglas on this so they
got seven oligarchs who have been
sanctioned by the uk just basically
taking their stuff first off why do
oligarchs thrive in the uk
several things one is is an obvious
thing which is that if you want to store
money somewhere and you've got an
unfeasibly large amount of money you
want to store it in somewhere stable a
stable country and britain common law
countries in general are seen as being
stable places to store money
um so that's the first thing the second
thing is is less pleasant which is that
undoubtedly in the last 20 years the uk
government successive uk governments
turned a blind eye to the money that was
coming in from russian oligarchs they
bought not just uh yachts and uh large
penthouses and apartments in belgravia
and so on but they bought football clubs
they bought chelsea football club owned
by roman abramovich they bought
newspapers uh a man who's who's now been
raised the house of lords who's a friend
of many politicians in the uk bought the
the independent newspaper and the
evening standard these were papers that
needed saving and the son of a kgb
operative
came to london and bought these papers
and people liked it they liked the money
these people splashed around i think it
was long long ago this should have been
seen to be shameful but now i mean you
just look at it and you think how
how did you think this was ever a good
idea you're talking about the ceo of uh
gazprom you're talking about the uh
chairman of vtb bank which is really
their government-owned bank and de
prescott who runs the en uh ian group
and you have uh the high profile guy
abramovic who just won a championship
and then had to sell his club and now
everybody wants to buy it so here's the
thing
they've taken their money from the
russian people they could cite they kept
it very concentrated way it made it
right for someone to overthrow yeltsin
for someone to step up like putin to
take over and putin turns around and
says you give me 50 you can keep your
money yeah so by sanctioning them can
they put pressure on putin or does he
have all the power and security well
that's a very interesting question
because one of the things that's become
clear recently has been particularly
with dara prasca who you just mentioned
who's brought up a lot of politicians
frankly in the uk
um
put favors around let's say um
and particularly with uh with with the
owner of chelsea football club these
people have not just been their own
money and this takes it it takes a
moment to realize this these these
people don't only own their own money
roma brown rich has four yachts
why does anyone need four yachts
no reason you can only be on one yacht
at a time it's because it seems at this
stage these people are to some extent
holding money for other people as well
they're holding things for other people
yachts for other people houses for other
people so we get back to this question
of
is one of the things in this that this
is also the way in which vladimir putin
stores his wealth in these hyper wealthy
individuals my argument would be go for
the oligarchs seize the things that they
have in the countries so that these
people see vladimir putin not as their
savior but as their curse if you could
turn that around maybe something changes
not just in ukraine but in the kremlin
there were but aren't there hundreds of
oligarchs
uh there's a significant number get them
all
well i think it would be a good thing
for the property market for general
peace in the world and for a lot more
right and i think the the takeaway is
why does anyone need seven yachts right
for sure douglas murray thanks so much
appreciate it hopefully we have better
news each and every week as we squeeze
all those close to vladimir putin hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else